In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose
of my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother
Mary and in the divine will of God.
And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep, and do everything.
May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires, and may you, my beloved
divine, will do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear
from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure, and that I remain so docile to the
movements of your divine will, that you never perceive even a breath of resistance in my
soul to your requests of me.
Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my
forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit, and infuse in me true light, so that I may
understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers, amen.
Well, for our last class before Christmas, the Lord is giving us a wonderful feast.
First of all, I want to begin in December the 20th, 1925, and here we have Jesus talking
about his experience of the Valley of Tears, and what he did with tears.
And I think there's stuff in here that we really need to look at and realize that he
has cried our tears for us, absolutely amazing, because very often when we are in a time of
mourning as Dolores is right now, or in a time of suffering, we think that we are crying
alone, we're not.
I was thinking of the tears that baby Jesus shed at his birth, and I said to myself, how
bitter those tears must have been for him, how they must have either frozen or burned
that tender face.
In fact, from what I know, tears have two effects, depending on the reason for which
they are shed.
If their cause comes from love, they burn and make one sob, but if they are produced
by sorrow, they are ice cold and they make one shiver.
From my royal little baby, there was intense and infinite love and also endless sorrow,
so his tears must have cost him very much.
Now while I was thinking about this, my sweet Jesus moved in my interior.
That's your Luke 17 21 and 1 Corinthians 3 16.
And he showed his face wet with tears, but with so many that one flowed after the other
to the point of wetting his chest and his hands.
And sighing, he said to me, my daughter, my tears began from the very first instant of
my conception, because he has explained elsewhere that he was conscious in his mother's womb.
Must be nothing worse.
And so he was aware of the darkness and the confinement and the inability to move and
so on.
And when you consider that he came from that interminable light that nobody can penetrate
unless he brings them there, it must have been unbelievable to be in confinement and darkness.
Sighing he said to me, my tears began from the very first instant of my conception in
the womb of my celestial mother and up to the last breath on the cross.
The will of my celestial father entrusted to me the task of tears, and this is the revelation.
And I was to shed so many of them from my eyes for as many creatures that would exist
on the earth.
In other words, he had to shed the tears of every single one of us.
And he's going to explain why.
Just as I conceived all their souls within me, so I was to shed all their tears as well.
Now what follows is absolutely amazing.
See then how much I had to cry.
I had to shed, this is number one, I had to shed from my eyes the tears, which people
shed out from passion so that mine would extinguish their passions.
Now when the word passion comes up, we have to understand that joy and laughter and sadness
and all the rest of it, they're all passions.
But if the Lord is trying to extinguish passions, he's talking about passions that have become
evils like anger that goes to hatred and attack.
Just to give just one example.
So if he is to extinguish our passions, it's that sinful side that he's actually talking
about.
I had to shed the tears which were needed after sin, this is the second area.
In order to give them the sorrow for having offended me.
In other words, for us to be able to experience real sorrow after sin so that we would never
go back into that disaster again.
He was the one who shed the tears for us, enabling us to have this grace.
And he shed tears that the conviction of the evil that they had done so that we would not
only go from sorrow but also into an absolute conviction about sin.
And of course, in the next message, he's going to tell us that we have to reach the point
that we'd rather die rather than sin.
And these tears he said prepared for the resolution not to offend me anymore.
Well, we have just seen how absolutely essential Jesus's tears are for our experience of repentance
and forgiveness and the resolution never to sin again.
His tears are essential to that because very often we don't shed tears and we don't feel
sorrow at the level we should and we don't feel the conviction of sin at the level we
should and we don't reach the point of saying I'd rather die than do that again.
And it's his tears that's actually enabling us to come to this point.
The third thing is I had to shed tears in order to move souls to compassion because human
beings can be very hard-hearted, to make them understand the pains of my passion because
it is possible to read about the passion just as something out there that you don't
actually enter in and participate with him and echo all his actions and all his words.
So the fourth area is that I had to shed abundant tears of love in order to electrify
souls to love me.
I love the expression he uses there, I had to electrify them to love me, it's like as
if he's saying I had to put a bomb on them to get them to actually love God because we
love ourselves and we love material things and we love the world and we love this passing
life and we love all kinds of stuff and we may not actually love God.
So I take the expression to electrify souls to make them love me and to draw their sympathy
and their hearts.
So you might go as far as sympathy but you might not actually give the heart.
You might not actually commit and so you'll see that Jesus here with this ministry of
tears actually won for us the grace to repent, to convert, to commit ourselves to God and
to really get into relationship with him.
So the heading I have over this paragraph from myself is through him with him and in
him.
We can do nothing by ourselves.
So I want to give you John 15, 5, without me you can do nothing Jesus said.
And then Philippians 4, 13, I can do all things in Christ who gives me the strength.
I can do nothing by myself.
So Jesus continues, "It's enough to tell you that there's not one tear that arises
on the human eye which I did not shed from my eyes."
I think that is something we need to look at with regard to our own sorrows.
How many times even as a tender child, I flew up from earth to heaven and leaning my little
head on the knees of my celestial father, I cried and cried and sobbing.
I said to him, "My father, you see, I am born in the world to tears and sorrows."
So my heading for the whole of this message is the valley of tears, of redemptive suffering.
I am born in the world to tears and sorrow just like my brothers who are also born to
tears and die amidst crying.
So there's no way we can get away from suffering and sorrow, the two severe companions that
God gives to us in this life to make absolutely sure that we stay on the right road and that
we persevere to the end.
And Jesus continues, "I love these brothers so much that I want to shed all of their
tears from my eyes, not even one do I want to let escape.
So as to give to their tears, tears of love, of sorrow, victory, sanctification and also
divinization."
Here Jesus is saying that in all of our sorrowful experiences and also tears of joy and tears
of love, he wants to raise these experiences to a higher level.
And in the next message he's going to continuously compare the lower level of just remaining
on the human level and the higher level of allowing him to raise us to a divinized life.
So Jesus continues, "How many times my dear mother in looking at me was pierced in seeing
me all wet and crying and because of the pain of seeing me cry, she united her tears
with mine and we cried together.
This is the echo and repeating.
We join him.
Shouldn't we cry for our world out there?
Shouldn't we cry for the condition of the church?
Shouldn't we cry for the terrible tribulation that's coming upon the world?
Oh yes we should.
And if you unite those tears with his tears, then they become redemptive and grace-filled
and grace-filling and many souls will be saved."
Jesus continues, "Sometimes I was forced
to hide myself to give vent to crying so as not to always pierce our mother's maternal
and innocent heart.
Other times I waited for the moment when my celestial mother out of necessity had to
occupy herself with housework, to give vent to my tears in order to complete the number
of tears for all creatures."
Just reading that would convince anybody that God actually loves us, that he wanted
every single experience of ours drenched in his grace and in his redemptive suffering
so that he could bring us through to the level that he wants to bring us to.
So Louisa said, "On hearing this I said to him, 'My love, Jesus, so your eyes also shed
my tears,' as well as those of our father, Adam."
So she goes all the way back to Adam and then down to herself, "And I want you to pour
them upon my soul to give me the grace not only to do your most holy will, that's the
lower level, the ordinary spirituality, but to possess your will, this is the higher level
of living in the divine will, to possess your holy will as my own thing and as my own will,
that the divine will is my will."
At that moment Jesus shook his head and from his face tears flowed onto my soul and he
added, "Daughter of my will indeed I did shed your tears, so that as they would pass through
my eyes, I might give you the gift of my will."
There you have it.
He's already shed my tears and yours to give us the gift of the divine will, so make sure
you get it before you go to bed.
"Indeed I shed your tears, so that they would pass through my eyes, I might give you the
great gift of my will, that which Adam could not receive with his tears because he had
rejected the divine will, even though they too passed through my eyes you can receive.
In fact before sinning Adam possessed my will and with the possession of my will he grew
in the likeness of his creation, so there's the high level, the above level, the ordinary
living at the level of the human will is the level of below.
So initially Adam did have the possession of the divine will and he grew in the likeness
of his creator and he grew so much as to form the enchantment of all heaven and all felt
honored in serving him, but after sin he lost the possession of the divine will, now notice
the possession of, he still had to do God's will, he's right down to the human level again.
And Jesus makes a very interesting revelation here.
He lost the possession of my will and even though he wept over his fault and he did not
sin again.
He was only able to do my will, that's the level of below and he was not able to possess
it which is the level of above.
So I think this message and the one that follows it is the clearest you'll ever get on living
in the divine will.
He said because the divine offended one was missing, that's the divine will.
The one who was to form the new divine graft between the creature and the creator in order
to let him cross again the thresholds of the possessions of the eternal volition.
So in the next paragraph, if you have your book the heading I have is choose either the
level of below or the level of above, it's entirely your choice.
The gift is there, he wants to give it.
He is paid for it, he's done all the preparation, he's given us all the information but we have
to choose.
This graft was made by me the eternal word after 4,000 years.
When Adam had already passed into the thresholds of eternity, notice the word thresholds because
nobody could go into heaven until redemption was completed.
So he goes into what people call limbo or whatever are the preparation places before
going into heaven.
But in spite of this divine graft done by me with tears and sighs and unheard of pains,
how many, this is number one, how many reduce themselves to the condition of Adam after sin
below level.
Others don't even want to know about the divine will.
I presume like myself, you have names, you could list off, they don't even want to know.
And thirdly, there are others who actually rebel against it, that's most of humanity.
So even with this studying of the revelation about the divine will, you could actually
stay at the lower level, do your own will.
When you know all this stuff, you may not actually chosen to let the Lord lift you up
onto this high level.
And so some people choose to stay on the lower level, some people don't want to know about
it at all.
I know people like that, lots of them.
And three, the vast majority just rebel against the divine will.
So only one who lives in my will rises to the state of Adam innocent, and this is as
clear as daylight.
In other words, only one who lives in the divine will can live at this higher level,
the level of above.
That's the state of Adam before he fell into sin.
In fact, there is a great distance between those who do my will and those who present
us.
And now we've been told that many times in the volumes leading up to this.
It is the same distance which passes between Adam innocent and Adam after sin.
There's a big word about Adam innocent and it's called pre-lapsarian Adam.
I'm sure you don't want big words.
Anyway, it's Adam before the fall and Adam afterward, a massive gulf between the two.
One is at this absolutely divine level and the other one's right down at the human level,
completely confined to our own puny intellect, our own puny reason and our own diseased will.
And Jesus continues, "And I in coming upon the earth was to act as God.
I was to complete the work of man in everything, including all our tears, as we've just heard.
I was to raise him to the first point of his origin.
That means to raise humanity right back to pre-lapsarian Adam."
Sorry for the big word, but I'm enjoying it.
So to raise us to the level of Adam before he fell by giving him the possession of my
will.
Now, only the possession of the divine will does this.
We're going to explain in the next message the difference between getting a loan of the
divine will and possessing it, two very different things.
So it's only those who have the possession of the divine will who are living at this
high level.
So I was to complete the work of man in everything.
I was to raise him to the first point of his origin by giving him the possession of my
will.
And even though many make use of my coming as remedy for their salvation, and therefore
take my will as medicine, as strength, and as antidote in order not to go to hell, that's
the lower level, I still wait that souls may rise and take the divine will as life and
make the divine will their own that they may take possession of it.
There's the higher level again.
In this way, I will complete the work of my coming on earth and the divine graft formed
anew with the creature will have fruit.
Then will my tears turn into celestial and divine smiles for me and for them?
It's a wonderful message.
So the following message is all about the gift of the divine will and I think that for those
of you who are teaching classes, you really need to take this off the page and make your
own notes on it because you're going to need this in your teaching of the classes because
it answers all the questions that the students want to ask you.
So Louisa said, I was thinking about what we've just said, that the divine will is a gift
and as a gift one possesses it as one's own.
On the other hand, one who does the will of God must submit to the commands.
So possession is up here, will of God is on the lower level and she gives us a very important
piece of discernment if you are giving spiritual direction to anybody else.
Watch this now.
One who does the will of God must submit to commands.
I can't kill anybody because I'm not allowed.
I can't divorce because I'm not allowed.
That's just submitting to a command.
Now watch this now and they ask very often what they must do.
Now I've given spiritual direction to people since 1980, it's a long while and the amazing
thing is the vast number that I have met that that is where they were at.
I don't even know what God is asking of me, they say.
I don't know where to go, start talking to them and sorting them out.
And if they make this expression to you at all, you know they're lost and they have
not reached into wanting the divine will to actually rule their lives.
Now watch this because the people she's talking about now are actually in the divine will
saying the right prayers and why aren't they in possession of the divine will.
So they want to be lent the gift, they want a loan of the gift.
That means I'm going to say at prayer in the divine will right now and for that prayer
I'm getting a loan of the divine will so it's on the divine level, then I go back and do
my own thing.
You get a loan of the divine will, you're not the owner of it.
And to do that action which God wants and once it's done you go back.
Now if you're in the divine will, I think that's a terrible tragedy.
So if you want to put a heading for yourself in your own book, I always put headings for
myself and my heading is another choice, borrow the gift or take it.
Do you feel comfortable if you borrow somebody else's machine to do something?
And you rather have your own, so let me read that again.
So the person on this lower level often ask what they must do and to be lent the gift,
not to be the owner of it, but to do that action which God wants and once it's done
they give back the gift that they borrowed and she said many images and simulates formed
in my mind about the one who lives the divine volition and possesses the gift and the one
who merely does the most holy will of God who not only does not possess the fullness
of the gift, but if he possesses it, it's only at intervals and on a loan.
So she's going to give us two examples.
And the first example is a gold coin in the next paragraph.
Okay, she said I imagined I had a gold coin and this coin had the power to make as many
coins as I wanted multiply.
She chooses the word arise for someone, a known reason as if a coin was alive.
Oh, how rich I would become with this gift.
On the other hand, someone else receives the gift as a loan for only an hour, so they don't
own the coin.
They have to give it back.
And for this hour, they carry out one action and then they have to give it back immediately.
What difference between my richness because I possess the gift and the one who only has
a for an hour?
That's the first example she gives.
I think that's a very good example.
The next example is on a higher plane because a coin is material.
So she said, next I imagined I had a gift of light, which never goes out.
That's much better because the divine will is light.
So both night and day, I'm safe, I have this gift.
I always have the good of seeing this light, which no one can take away from me because
mine.
It becomes as though a natural part of me and it gives me the good of knowing what is good
in order to do it and what is evil in order to escape it.
So with this light that I have received as a gift, the next statement is a bit funny.
So I've changed it into something better.
It says I sneer as everything.
I couldn't imagine Louise sneering.
I laugh at the world, at the enemy, at my passions, and even at myself.
And all the things that can pull you down, you just say, no, I've got the answer because
I've got this light shining all the time.
And this, of course, is the divine will guiding us from within.
Now this light is a perennial source of happiness for me.
It is without weapons and yet it defends me.
It is without voice and yet it instructs me.
It's without hands and feet and yet it directs my way, making itself the sure guide to bring
me to heaven.
So beside that, I want you to put two Corinthians 10 for the weapons of our warfare are not
carnal, but they're mighty for the pulling down of strongholds.
And these strongholds are the enemy by passions at the world and my even my own self and my
own ego.
So on the other hand, someone else has to go and ask for this light when he feels the
need for it.
And therefore, he doesn't have it at his disposal.
Not being used to always looking with this light.
He does not possess the knowledge of good and evil.
I would think she's talking about you don't have the ability to discern, to see through
things.
If it's good and evil, you have to be able to discern.
It's like using a search light and you say, oh, there's a branch has fallen off the tree
in front of my house, I can see it with the light.
So the person who doesn't own the light is not able to recognize the good from the bad
and hasn't enough strength to do good and avoid evil.
Now notice this light is the source of strength because it's the divine will, the source of
everything.
So not possessing the light turned on and continuous.
Now we're given here very, very simply messages that we've heard over and over again in the
volumes leading up to this.
That living the divine will is every nanosecond, there's no timeout.
And if you're living the divine will, you will know that because you wake up in the middle
of the night and you're still in contact with the divine will, you're still talking to him.
And you talk to him in your sleep as well.
So not possessing the light turned on and continuous in how many deceptions, dangers
and narrow ways does he not find himself.
So in other words, you're in the tripping and falling area.
What a difference between one who possesses the light as his own gift and one who has
to ask for it just as alone.
So one of the things I love about these writings is that when you get the message, there isn't
any choice, you can't possibly have a loan of something you really should own yourself.
So in the next paragraph, this is the gift, the possession of the divine will.
And Jesus calls it divine currency as well, that this is very rich and very wonderful.
Now Louisa said, while my mind wandered amid many similes, I said to myself, so the living
in the will of God is to possess the will of God and this is a gift.
There she's given you a perfect summary.
You live in the will of God and it's God's gift, you can't earn it, it's not possible.
Okay, so there you have it, therefore, if the goodness of God does not condescend to
give this gift, what can a poor creature do?
Very good question.
At that moment, my beloved Jesus moved in my interior as though clasping me all to himself
and he told me, my daughter, it's true that living in my will is a gift.
And it's true that it is to possess the greatest gift, but this gift, which contains infinite
value.
Number one, it is divine currency that arises at each instant.
Here I said every nanosecond at each instant.
Number two, it is divine currency, which is light that never goes out.
Number three, it's divine currency, which is sun and never sets.
Number four, it's divine currency, which puts the soul in her place established by God in
the divine order.
Wow.
Number five, it is divine currency, therefore, that she takes her place of honor in the
sovereignty of creation.
Romans 8, 19, she's one of the true sons of God.
This is given only to one A, who is disposed, B, to one who will not waste it, C, to one
who will esteem it so much, and D, to one who will love it more than their own lives,
and E, even more, that this person would be ready to sacrifice their own lives so that
this gift of the divine will may have supremacy over everything, and be held more than life
itself, even more his life is nothing compared to the gift.
There you have it.
It's the whole thing, and it's given with absolutely succinct order.
So I suggest if you're a teacher of a class, get a large sheet of paper, write all this
out separately so that you have very clear guidance and teaching to give to everybody
else.
This is the wonderful thing about studying the higher volumes when you're teaching the
lower volumes, because then you can give the people at the lower volumes the insights
that they will get later on, and they have the whole thing.
You're actually giving them the entire picture.
That for me is a very, very wonderful thing.
And notice he calls it divine currency, because with the gift of the divine will, we are free.
We are free to go and release souls from predatory, and we're free to give the infinite merits
of the precious blood of Jesus to all souls past, present and future.
You can do so much.
So I think there are journeys that we have to take.
I don't know when you do it, but my favorite time is that night when I'm in bed and I'm
supposed to be sleeping.
I don't know.
The semi-darkness really helps, and we go on journeys together.
Louisa often went on journeys.
She'd go to the sick, and she'd go to the dying, and she'd go to the souls in purgatory,
and she'd go to the soldiers out on the wars and all the rest of it, and she was taking
the precious blood of the Lamb to save them, and she was doing everything that the Lord
wanted her to do.
And I think we've got to go on journeys like that.
I enjoy journeys like that, because it's many years now, long before I got into the
divine will, that the Lord showed me that when you pray, you have no limitation of time
or space.
When you pray, you actually enter into his dimension, and that you can visit any prison
you like, and talk to the prisoners.
You can visit any hospital you like.
You can visit any people.
You can visit all the lonely, all the poor.
Absolutely everybody.
You can talk to the people on the streets.
You can talk to the refugees.
You can go anywhere.
There's absolutely no limits once you enter into him in prayer.
To do that at the divine will level gives you infinite power at your disposal as well.
I mean, the privilege is beyond anything I can express.
So what are we to do?
We have this extraordinary gift offered to us.
And in the next paragraph, Jesus is going to say something unbelievably simple.
And that is, I only give it to people who ask for it.
You know, we're used to going into a supermarket and seeing all kinds of food there, and the
more elaborate the food, the less I want it.
And you can come out to the supermarket with a very humble little basket.
With stuff that is not representative of all the riches that are there, you might want
it.
In fact, the more elaborate the stuff is, the less I want it.
And so we have to make sure we've arrived at the point where we actually do want the gift.
And so some of us may need to actually convince ourselves, first of all, and then convince
the Lord, we actually want it.
So watch this.
Therefore, Jesus is speaking.
First, I want to see that the soul really wants to do my will and never her own.
This stage one, that's why I've told all of you who have been on my classes, particularly
in the early volumes, that our module has to be not my will, but thine be done, particularly
when you're crossed.
And you really want to do something and at that the moment when you want to do it, somebody
else just says, absolutely no, you can't do that.
Not my will, but thine be done, not my will.
And if we really exercise ourselves really well in not my will, but thine be done, then
we can turn it around and say, Lord, I choose everything you choose from me.
That's what St. Therese of this you said, I choose everything you choose from me.
So the first thing is, I want to see that the soul really wants to do my will and never
her own.
The second thing is, I want to see that she's ready to make any sacrifice in order to do
my will.
That's a different stage now.
Because initially, it's the choice to actually do his will.
And then the second one was, would you make a sacrifice in order to do it?
So you said, I need to see that she's actually ready to make a sacrifice in order to do my
will.
Because if you're ready to make a sacrifice, that means you're ready to actually put aside
what you want.
That's why I think the exercise of not my will, but thine be done, is terribly important
in the early days.
Thirdly, he said, I want to see that in everything she does, she always asks me for the gift
of my will.
Notice the little word, everything she does.
Because living in the divine will is every nanosecond, okay?
So he wants to know, are we choosing this at every single second of our being?
So notice he has to try and find out if he can trust us.
We can trust him, but can he trust us?
So the third one was that I want to see that in everything she does, she always asks me
for the gift of my will, even if it's just alone initially.
He's very humble, you know, and he knows we can be quite reluctant to change our ways.
So initially, he will accept that you're just asking for a loan.
Then fourthly, when I see that she does nothing without the loan of my will, in other words,
she is borrowing this frequently, frequently, frequently, frequently, and more frequently,
then he said, I give it as a gift.
Because by asking for it over and over again, what it's going to say now is extremely important.
By asking for it over and over again, the soul has actually made space for the divine
will to take up occupancy there.
If I'm full of my own will and full of my own opinion and full of my own importance,
there's no room for anybody, there's no room for anything.
So in all of these early stages, what we're actually doing is clearing out the house and
making sure that there is actually a place, a throne, for God to reign in our hearts.
Christmas is a very good time for this.
We make room in our Bethlehem.
We make room in our cave, we make room in our crib, whatever language you want to use.
But he has to have a throne, and he wants to reign in us, but he wants to reign through
us as well.
That's the incredible thing about him.
So by asking for the gift, Jesus says over and over again, she has formed the void within
her soul in which to place this celestial gift.
And by becoming used to living with the loan of this divine food, she's lost the taste
for her own will.
Now notice he is telling us that we need a lot of exercise, we are creatures of habit.
And you mightn't have a taste for doing God's will.
If you've been doing your own will all the time.
And so, so an act, reap a habit.
So a habit, reap a character.
So a character, reap a destiny.
So it's act by act by act by act that we actually build this up.
It's entirely up to ourselves.
So she has formed within herself the place or the room or the throne where the divine
will can actually reign.
And by becoming used to living with the loan of this divine food, she loses taste for the
other.
And her palace has been ennobled and will no longer adapt itself to the vile foods of
herself well.
Therefore, in seeing herself in possession of that gift which he longed for, yearned for,
and loved so much, she will live of the divine will.
She will live now at this higher plane.
And she will love it.
She will give it the esteem that it actually deserves.
So now we have been divinized and we're living at this divine level.
That's very precious material and it's as clear as daylight.
And then Jesus gives an example.
Would you not condemn a man who, taken by a childish affection for a child, only to
have him around for a little bit, to amuse himself with him and he'd give him a bank
note worth a thousand, whatever your currency is.
And the little boy not knowing the value of it tears up the piece of paper.
Don't you think that first of all he would make the child understand the meaning of the
bank note, that he would get a child to actually want it, that he would get the child to understand
its value and only after all of this preparation he would then give him the bank note.
So that illustration is to fit what we've just been talking about.
He can't give us the gift overnight.
We wouldn't appreciate it, we wouldn't know its value, we wouldn't use it.
We would be like the child, we'd tear it up without realizing what we were tearing up.
And so he's telling us that we only grow gradually in our appreciation of the gift
of the divine will.
And that's one of the reasons for this constant study of the volumes of Louisa.
And those of you who have got up to the higher volumes and even completed the 36 volumes,
many of us have, when you go back to the earlier ones, it's like as if you were starting all
over again and it's totally fresh and you're, it's wonderful.
So we need to be doing this all the time, okay.
You don't give this thousand pound note, I didn't know there was a thousand pound note
but never mind, you don't give this to a child who doesn't know its value, okay.
So if man does this, Jesus said, I do it even more who with my gifts of wisdom, with justice
and with true love that he deals with us, here is therefore the necessity for the dispositions
of the knowledge of the gift and of the esteem and appreciation and the love for the gift.
All of which you will get by studying the volumes and by putting it into practice.
Therefore the knowledge of this gift is like the herald of the gift of the divine will
that I want to give to the person.
Knowledge prepares the way you've heard me saying that now for 10 years.
Knowledge is like the contract that I want to make of the gift that I want to give and
the more knowledge I give to the soul, the more she is spurred on to desire the gift
and to solicit the divine writer to place the final signature.
In other words this is a contract you and I are making and I will put the final signature
on it as soon as you're ready.
Now notice he doesn't tell us we have to be special or we have to have special education
or you have to have a special character or background or anything, not none of that.
It's just what he has told us that your soul is ready, that's all.
That's just the wonderful thing about him.
The sign in these times that I want to give the gift is the fact that you have the knowledge
of the divine will available to you.
If you're studying these volumes you know for certain, God wants to give you the gift
and that's it, it's entirely up to you.
Louisa then goes, she's very practical, she gets all of this wonderful teaching and then
all of a sudden she's going to a little exercise.
So she goes in to a little exercise and she says but my little act is so small, I can't
see where it goes and I can't see its destiny or anything else.
So after this my poor mind was wandering in the supreme volition and I did as much as
I could in order to do all my acts in the divine will.
Now I love the expression I did as much as I could.
The Lord does the rest, we do hope we can.
I felt invested with the supreme light because the divine will is the supreme light and my
little acts as they came out of me they took their place within the light and were converted
into light so they're divinized and I could see neither the point of the light in which
I had done them nor where they were to find them.
I could only see that they had become incorporated into that light.
Taken up into God our little tiny acts they had been incorporated into that endless light
and nothing else and it was impossible for me to navigate through that inaccessible light.
Now one Timothy 616 tells us that God lives in inaccessible light and the exact words
are given here.
So how can you navigate the immensity and the eternity of God?
We're only tiny little creatures.
But to cross the whole of it is not given to my littleness.
That moment my beloved Jesus moved in my interior and he told me, "My daughter, how beautiful
is the operating of the soul in my will.
Her act unites to the single act of the Creator.
He is a singularity.
All one act and everything else comes out of it.
Even the astronomers are beginning to get that point and this one act knows no succession
of acts even though all acts are incorporated into it.
In fact the eternal light is not divisible and if it could be divided which cannot be
the separated part would become darkness."
Now there's a huge statement because that's what happened to Lucifer and the fallen angels.
Once they separated from the divine light they became darkness and that was the origin
of hell.
So if anything is separated from that one divine act of God it becomes darkness.
So we're coming out of a dark world of unbelief learning from the Lord how to enter into him
at a divine level and how to make our acts through him with him and in him in the divine
level.
So our little acts go into that light are accepted by God.
I find it mind-boggling.
So the operating in the light of my volition, the soul unites herself to that single act
of her Creator and takes her place within the atmosphere of the eternal light.
Now if I was to say that in Simple English I would say your act has gone to heaven, it's
gone back to God.
This is why you cannot see your acts either at the point of the light in which you perform
them or where they are now because it is impossible for the creature to cross the whole of the
eternal light of God.
Although she knows that her act is certainly present in the light, notice certainly present.
You don't have to doubt her.
And her act takes its place in the past, the present and the future because outside of
time and space, which we have on planet earth, everything is one, past, present and future
are all present to God.
Once the act enters into God, it enters into the past, present and future.
That's why we can go back and pick up the acts of Adam and all the people gone before
us.
And then he gives an example of the sun which he does very frequently in these writings.
Look at the sun, being the image of the shadow of the divine light, it possesses this property
in part because it's a source of light for us.
Suppose you were operating in a place upon which the sun spreads its solar light, you
see its light in front of you above and behind you on the right and on the left, so you're
completely surrounded by light.
As you can see from my picture, I'm sorry, completely surrounded by light.
Now, if you wanted to see which part of the light of the sun that surrounded you completely,
you wouldn't be able to do it, you couldn't find it.
You would only say that the light was certainly upon you.
Now that light was there from the first instance in which the sun was created, I think that
is an absolutely fantastic thought.
The light that's shining on us in our daylight has been shining on the earth since creation.
It is and it will be.
If your act could convert into solar light as it converts into the divine light, would
you be able to find your particle of light and the light which was given to you by the
sun in order to let you work at all?
Of course you wouldn't.
However, you know that the act has come out of you, that's number one.
You know that it was incorporated into the light of the sun, that's two.
And so this is why I say that the living in the supreme volition is the greatest thing
it is to live the divine life on the earth.
Quite literally through living in the divine will we're bringing heaven down to the earth.
We're bringing light into the darkness, we're bringing grace to where sin is and needs to
be dispersed.
And so we're part of the solution for planet earth that consoles me.
As soon as God sees the soul in his will, the celestial creator takes her up in his arms,
placing her on his lap, he lets her operate with his own hands.
I'm as fantastic.
The image you have there is absolutely incredible, it's like a daddy and he takes a little child
up on his lap and the child wants to do something and the daddy helps the child to do it.
So here we are on the father's lap actually doing divine things simply because he enables
us to do them.
Look at the love that's there and look at the immeasurable humility of God in letting
this happen.
So he places the soul on his lap, he lets her operate with his own hands and with the power
of that fiat with which all things were made.
He lets all his reflections descend upon that soul.
In order to give her the likeness of his operating, there are a whole lot of sams that I could
give you but I'm only going to give you two, Sam 8611 and Sam 254, not in the right order,
I should give you the lower one first and it's Lord, teach us your ways.
Now if you look at the sams for Advent, you will find that frequently the church is saying
Lord, teach us your ways.
His ways are divine.
His ways are so far above ours, as Isaiah said in Isaiah 55, 8 to 10, as different from
the heavens and the earth is his way and his way of thinking.
So Lord, teach us your ways.
So those of us who want to truly live this divine life, then we sit on his lap, let him
teach us his ways.
So that means that our way of thinking will be transformed, our way of looking at things,
our way of assessing things, we will see them in God's light, we will see them from the
way he sees them, we will assess things with his assessment, not with the assessment of
the world.
So this is why the operating of the soul becomes light because it unites to that single act
of our Creator and constitutes itself eternal glory and continuous praise of our Creator,
therefore be attentive, let the living of my will be for you, your all, that you may never
descend from your origin, that is from the lap of your Creator, where you came from.
Now that's an extremely important statement in the world we're living in and the tragedy
that's going to be visited to us in the near future.
We need to remember to stay where we came from, clinging to the person who gave us life,
thinking the way he thinks, doing the way he does.
So thank you for coming and I wish you a very happy and holy Christmas.
God bless.